- Your music is inspiring
other young women,
which is incredible. But
there's one particular fan,
I love this story-
- [Lainey] Yes.
- That you helped recently right?
- Absolutely, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I feel like, I'm in a position-
- From this story I feel like
we can be a friends, go. Okay.
- [Lainey] Okay, yeah I know-
(crowd laughs)
- Yeah.
- When you saw it,
you were like: oh, we gonna hit it off.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah. (laughs)
- I feel like I'm, I'm starting
to like be in a position
to where I can actually give
back and kind of help people-
- Yeah.
- Up and it feels really nice.
I mean, we're even doing
this emerging artist program
with Tractor Supply, but this specific
- Awesome.
- Story is so crazy.
We were in New York City
and I was playing my,
I'm on my very first
headlining tour right now.
- Yeah. Congratulations, by the way.
(applause)
(cheering)
- And it has been-
- That's so cool.
- Awesome. It has been so
awesome, but I see this sign
out in the crowd and I've got
terrible vision, so I'm kinda
like squinting, trying to see it,
and it says "will you sign my forehead?"
And I'm like, "Absolutely,
you better get up here,
I'm gonna sign your forehead!"
(Kelly laughs)
But when she gets closer, I
realized that a week prior
this little girl had put
up a TikTok about people
making fun of the way she dressed.
She dressed like me at school, and I-
- You look like you're straight up
outta Fleetwood Mac, I love your look.
- Yeah, and I think that
kind of scares some people
but this little girl it did not scare her.
So when I realized that was her,
I brought her up on stage and I had her
sign my forehead, too. (laughing)
- [Kelly] I, I love that.
(crowd applauding)
- Yeah. (laughing)
- That's so cool.
- It made my night. It did.
That's what it's all about-
- And tell her all those
girls making fun of you
are gonna peak in high school-
- [Lainey] That's right,
that's right.
- Like we were talking about.
- Yup, that's right.
(laughter)
- Zach-
- All those quarterbacks
are all fat and bald now.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Lainey] That's right.
- You know what I mean?
(Kelly laughing)
(crowd laughing)
- All those Nerds?
- Uh-huh.
- Check it out.
- Check it out!
(burst of applause)
- Look at these buttons. (laughing)
So wait, Zachary, wait.
Do you have a favorite moment
with a fan that you met
like on a street or at a
convention or anything?
- Uuuuhm-
- You probably have many.
- I mean, I don't know.
- Some interesting ones.
- Yeah, I think the one,
honestly, the, the, the fan
the ones that I remember the
most are when I meet people
like a conventions and things like that,
who tell me that something that I've done,
whether it's Chuck or Tangled
or Shazam or whatever,
like resonated with them
on a very deep level
and helped them through
a time in their life
that otherwise would've
been way too dark, you know?
- That's right. That's right.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, you know, people
losing loved ones and then they
they find Chuck and it helped
buoy their soul like that
as an artist, as an entertainer-
- That's what great Art is supposed to do.
- Yeah that's absolutely what-
- [Lainey] Exactly.
- You're hoping to do.
So, that's all the stuff-
- [Lainey] I love that.
- that I remember most.
And people wanted me to
sign their baby's faces
but you know, that's.
(laughter)
- Now, that's too far.
- That's too far.
(Laughter)